what the hell happened last
night my last
night let's do this right and have a
proper honeymoon I love you pigeon
welcome to gatito
[Applause]
[Music]
Mexico you it's just crossed the
threshold well this isn't too
barbaric no but it was so cute with our
initials on it TNA cuz you got the
best this marriage is starting off on
the wrong
foot don't you want to have some
fun this is not about his needs this
marriage about your
needs you cannot disrespect the power of
the please tell me that's not
Abby it's definitely Abby what happened
to Manny petties
what are you doing you said it was a top
of speech that doesn't apply to
foreigners leave me alone
[Music]
I
really I love you
pigeon this is a pro con list just to
see if we should get a quick analment I
even gave his head start because you
have the biggest who just got the
big look I know I can be possessive
what on they you're suffocating her
she's my wife she has a bad habit of
Disappearing and I don't want that to
happen to either of us we want you to
fight for
her you don't see what's staring you
right in the
face love I don't even know what to
say you could say
[Music]
yes
thank